puis vous n'êtes pas du tout handicaper
dominique l'origine n'irait pas loin
sans nom vous occuper de la chronique
éducation et pour cela il faut avoir
tous ses moyens et vous occupez surtout
de la chronique racontez-nous l'école
oui le crédit bien monsieur le
professeur puisque vous distribue les
bons points alors on va distribuer des
parfums aux écoles maternelles de lattes
reçu ebooks que dans la creuse toutes
les écoles ont des cours de mus alors je
vous invite à un bilan de musique mais
un cours de musique assez extraordinaire
puisqu'il ya dans la classe un
professeur prestigieux ce n'est pas noël
mamère ou nous suivre et british il et
nous allez voir que les gosses avec eelv
et gitlis font un travail assez tenant à
reportage de nahla richardon pardon
alors on regarde cela avec
et pourquoi tu deviens toi l'archet
comme ça
c'est comme ça
pour ivry gitlis tous les enfants
devraient pouvoir dès leur plus jeune
âge découvrir le monde de la musique et
le considérer comme famille pour ces
enfants de la creuse la venue du grand
professionnel constitué donc un
événement eu la récompense si de leur
travail car ici à guéret on apprend le
violon dès les premiers mois d'école
attention vous jouez simplement pas moi
ses juges une forge des forces et je
doucement on fait du soin et c'est
assurément pas
vous avez chanté dans votre date en même
temps
tu penses tu
après un mois d'apprentissage les
résultats sont déjà sensibles et les
enfants ont pris goût à la musique le
violon à l'école une expérience qui
exige de la part des enseignants une
compétence à la fois pédagogique et
technique vous même depuis combien de
temps vous êtes vous mis au volant
depuis deux ans depuis l'expérience a
commencé dans l'école
une fois par semaine nous allons l'école
normale suivre des cours
les cours ont lieu deux fois par semaine
et dure de 5 à 15 minutes quelques
enfants se distingue rapidement il
arrive que certains parents tentent eux
aussi d'expérience gaël n'a jamais
appris seul fais mais après deux ans de
violon il peut aujourd'hui interprété
des morceaux plus difficile en
travaillant après l'école
femi noir et puis après
je joue ma maman me dit de jouer puis je
joue je m'entraîne beaucoup et puis
après je tous les deux pris mona moi je
veux tu sais la gavotte et bien on a vu
à à vous dira je maman
bon allez tu la joues aux gens comment
tu l'as fait
j'ai appris avec lui comme ça et puis au
fur et à mesure bon ben je me suis
laissé prendre au jeu et puis j'ai
continué avec lui et puis alors
maintenant bon bah maintenant moi je ne
suis plus par contre il est plus en
avance que moi
et
d'abord faire rencontrer les rediffusent
fille caden questions à lui poser qu'est
ce que tu lui jamais posée comment tu
veux aussi bien comment je mets qui t'a
dit que je joue bien tu trouve que je
joue bien ou
alors tu peux faire la même chose c'est
très simple du grand marché j'ai fait ça
plus tôt tu l'a très bien fait tout à
l'heure
mais quoi
c'est gentil de me dire je suis pas
tellement sûr moi je trouve que tu fait
très très bien seulement il faut il faut
continuer à faire
bien